little date guys who just mooch off of
them
and like she has the place she's taking
care of bills and he's like the one
who's channeling
um what what's the phrase a pookie or
ray yeah she's usually a good looking
guy a good looking guy who's smooth
he may not be going anywhere he's going
but he's literally looking good
he's six foot he's chiseled but he lives
in the hood and he's not trying to get
out like yeah
that's that's the good genes that's like
the alpha side because there's
there's two parts of hypergamy that they
talk about and
it's um alpha alpha fox and beta bucks
and so okay
i'm sure so out of the guys that you
guys have like slept with dated whatever
i'm sure you can think of a guy
where immediately like you wanted to
sleep with him like right off the bat
like oh my god he's so fine versus the
other guy who he kind of had to be your
friend first he kind of had to like
kind of have to like weasel his way in
there and then over time you're like you
know what
she's laughing
i think i've heard
like some of my friends and people or
acquaintances i know have like yeah it
took them some time like oh it took me
some time to warm up too but yeah that's
good now
or like the ones like oh he's fine i
would
i would have his babies or something
like that you know yeah and so that's
that's like the two ways that girls look
at guys so
they call it alpha fox which that means
he has good genes basically okay um
maybe i think
you guys let me know in the chat would
you say social status is included in
alpha [ __ ]
because i don't know i think it may be
um like game i would say maybe it's been
there but and then beta bucks is someone
you see as a long-term provider and
there's different mating strategies that
women have so one is they want someone
to continue um
legacy basically so he won't cheat on
you publicly he won't embarrass the
family like that sort of thing so pookie
and ray-rays don't have that
no legacy with them but what they might
have is good genes they might have um
social status which is like that's why a
guy with a blue check mark
like he might not even be cute or
whatever but like
if he's got a blue check mark like girls
are coming yeah yeah yeah
and then there's there's long term
security which is like
either they think he might not maybe
have a lot of money but they know he
would stick around and take care of the
kid or he he's a provider he has that
money
okay so oftentimes girls will marry the
beta guy that they're really not as
attracted to but they know he's the
better father for their kids
have a couple kids with them and cheat
with the alpha guy or get the beta if
they can really fulfill their mating
strategy they will
marry the beta guy and get pregnant by
the alpha guy and have the beta guy
raise the kids
oh god
wouldn't that be like a part of in a
sense of good guys finish last yes yeah
okay and that's part of the red pill for
men is realizing
that the nice guys don't finish last
because in society they've always been
told that
be nice you know get a job be be a
provider type of guy and you will get
the best results and so it's like these
guys do that and then they're like where
are my [ __ ]
where where the hose at
i'm here but then we look but then you
look at the guys you know the bad guys
and you know the bad boys and the reboys
and the rappers and the athletes and the
staff but they're getting all the girls
this is a question to the guys oh
was there an age where you made
the change
and do you remember that do you remember
what age you were when you
finally made that change what kind of
change
because maybe it was just me i used to
be this huge sweet boy some people could
call me a simple if you look back here
but there's usually a point in a lot of
men's life and i've seen it with a lot
of my friends there's an age there's a
time right
where the change happens
it might be for a little bit you might
go back to being a sweet boy but like a
lot of people i know go through
like the wall but it's different for
guys is the switch because it goes from
like i'm gonna i'm gonna take on dates
and i'm gonna buy your flowers every day
so you know what yeah
[Music]
okay it's kind of like okay if a guy
says hey babe can you please be quieter
shut the [ __ ] up which one are you more
attracted to
because in my head if someone's telling
me shut the [ __ ] up i'm gonna cuss them
out too like we're just gonna have a
battle like i can't but it depends on if
you're attracted to him or not um
if someone that you're not attracted to
tells you to shut the [ __ ] up
i feel like you're capping me
if you're not attracted to the guy and
he told you shut the [ __ ] up you'll bark
up but if you're attracted to him like
if he's unattractive or attractive
i'm gonna i
i will argue back i will say something
back i'm not just gonna be like okay
i'm not gonna do that
i can't like i can't do that michael
jordan has a tear in the in his
raspberry little voice like yo babe shut
the [ __ ] up
i just said no i can't
there are some women that are like i
love it when he tells me to shut the
[ __ ] up i love it i can't do that but
it's it's a guy it's basically like we
don't like guys that kick kiss our ass
that's why you see that's why you see
okay will and jada why doesn't she
respect him
because he's been putting her on a
pedestal like you see him at the red
corporate event that's about him and
he's he's going like this to her
oh yeah yeah like we hate that because
it's like i feel like girls know on some
level that none of us are [ __ ] like we
all and [ __ ] so if you're treating us
like we're the [ __ ] we're like what's
wrong with you
why are you it's like because it's true
the guy buys you flowers and takes you
on an extravagant first date you're like
why
why what i'm like that but you like it
but in the back of your head you're like
why like like you why you haven't done
that
okay why are you doing that yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
what was your question again oh do you
guys remember or did did you guys ever
go through a point in your life where a
change happened
right that like someone might have hurt
you or you started to see the world in a
different light and you're no longer the
nice guy who takes people out as much as
you did you're now the guy who just
plays the field as much as you can even
you know it might be for a little bit
yeah no i think i think i may have gone
through that change i think it happens
yeah but it was heartbreak it went of
course same
but that's what i think is for most guys
it's hard
for me it was the other way around oh he
broke her heart no no for me
for me it was
um i was really like
i was i didn't care about it what anyone
thought like if
if i had a girlfriend i don't care what
you think
i was kind of like that but then i kind
of switched okay i became more caring
and more
you know i asked what changed
and why i think it was the circle that i
kept to get me i had a lot of female
friends but then and those always you
know give you advice that you know
relationship advice you know make your
girl feel welcomed and make her feel
nice and stuff like that and it was like
all that advice turns you into a simp
kind of thing
and then you start doing too much and
then when you talk start doing too much
the girls kind of switch
so it's like before they used to like me
when i was a waste man or not always
about a [ __ ] yeah like getting me i
used to talk to you anyhow and you would
like that and
when i'm actually being respectful and
nice and you know opening the door and
doing all these gentlemen things yeah
you're trying to take my weakness oh my
kindness for weakness kind of thing so
it's like
that's for me that's so it happened the
opposite and then kind of switched back
when the red pill kind of came along
that's when i was like okay now i
realize and it's kind of
gone back
but i was kind of doing it doing i was
kind of red pill subconsciously yeah
yeah without even knowing when you were
at red turn blue red
i've heard this story from so many guys
where they say oh i was
so nice to these girls and i realized
they don't like that yeah
and so i stopped doing it and then i got
more girls yeah you think but don't you
think it's like what
women i guess like what women are used
to now so like house
yeah so like our generation now like
they don't care about really it doesn't
seem like they care about taking girls
out to eat anymore and doing like those
kind things and so they're so used to
like
guys not doing anything or talking to
them however so do it they're just like
what the hell is going on yeah like why
are you doing it why are you doing it
yeah this is the reason behind that you
need something in the egg situation i
think i think it's that we're all going
for the same men
and so those guys don't have the time to
take us out on dates because we're
picking the guys that everyone wants
[Music]
because i'm saying there's a chicken in
the egg situation mr you can't which you
think came first the guy's kind of not
treating the girls as nicely as they
that they did prior to because the girls
didn't want it or
the girls or the girls having the
burdens which do you think came first
men will do anything to get laid yeah
like they will
taking us on dates and being chivalrous
got them like yeah
yeah yeah i think if [ __ ] like if girls
were required chivalry
killed it well when it like back in the
like way back in the day like the
the housewives you know the love that
when it when weren't they more like
shiva like oh i'll tell you why birth
control changed the game yeah in 1965
when they developed birth control that
was that was the beginning of modern
women
because then girls got the opportunity
just to
screw the guys
like the alpha alpha thugs
where before they had to pick a beta guy
and because they didn't have anything to
compare it to they were they were pretty
happy and their dads would maybe help
them a little bit the guys so they could
say that guy would be a good long-term
partner because you know a lot of girls
were virgins back then yeah but so now
girls get ran through throughout their
20s screwing all the the bad boys and
then expect a beta guy to pick up the
pieces at 30.
wow
so it fulfills both mating strategies
that's why girls argue so hard for
abortion and for birth control
because they they want the best of both
worlds